OK, so there is, of course, a seismic historic change going on right now in the Republican Party this year. And one of our producers, Zoe Chace, told me about this place where you can eavesdrop on a group of friends, idealistic Republican friends, as they fret and cope and argue about that change week after week. And there is a lot of pain. Zoe has been covering Donald Trump and the Republican Party for our show all year, and every week she listens to this podcast called Ricochet as soon as it goes up.
当然，共和党今年正在经历一场巨大的历史性变革。我们的制片人之一，佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace），告诉了我一个地方，在那里你可以偷听到一群朋友，一群理想主义的共和党朋友，他们每周都在为这种变化感到焦虑、应对并争论。那真的很痛苦。佐伊今年一直在为我们的节目报道唐纳德·特朗普（Donald Trump）和共和党，每周只要那个名为《Ricochet》的播客一上线，她就会立刻去听。
The three hosts of Ricochet describe themselves as center-right. They're basically Reagan Republicans. In fact, one of them was actually a Reagan speechwriter. And like old school Republicans all over the country, this year, they've been trying to square their old school conservative ideals with their game changing nominee and with what they see their party turning into. Here's Zoe.
《Ricochet》的三位主持人自称是中间偏右派。他们基本上是里根共和党人。事实上，其中一位曾是里根的演讲撰稿人。和全国各地的老派共和党人一样，今年，他们一直在试图将他们老派的保守主义理想与他们那场改变游戏规则的候选人以及他们所看到的政党转变结合起来。请听佐伊的报道。
And the thing that's emerged is, one of the hosts, Rob Long, he cannot be convinced to get behind Donald Trump. And he's in pain over the whole thing. And then one of the other hosts, Peter Robinson, is a reluctant Trump supporter. And he brings on people that try to make all of them feel OK about supporting the Republican nominee for president. And Rob Long just isn't buying it.
结果出现的情况是，其中一位主持人罗伯·朗（Rob Long）无法被说服去支持唐纳德·特朗普。他因为整件事而感到痛苦。而另一位主持人彼得·罗宾逊（Peter Robinson）则是勉强支持特朗普的。他请来了一些人，试图让所有人都能心安理得地支持这位共和党总统候选人。但罗伯·朗根本不买账。
Like, one time this scholar named Larry Arnn, who's also president of Hillsdale College, he came on the show with research into Donald Trump's writings and statements going back years.
比如，有一次，一位名叫拉里·阿恩（Larry Arnn）的学者，他同时也是希尔斯代尔学院（Hillsdale College）的校长，他带着对唐纳德·特朗普多年来文章和言论的研究来到了节目中。
And we find things going back to 1990 or in '91, and they are consistent. Donald Trump is engaged in a major assault upon the regulatory state. And it is the most full-throated one that I have heard since Ronald Reagan.
我们发现了追溯到1990年或91年的东西，它们是一贯的。唐纳德·特朗普正在对监管国家发动一场重大攻击。这是我自罗纳德·里根以来听到的最直言不讳的一次。
Rob Long is also on the line.
罗伯·朗也在连线中。
I'm having a mini stroke here.
我快要中风了。
Rob, we'll come to you in a moment.
罗伯，我们待会儿再找你。
And then Rob comes in always in pain.
然后罗伯总是带着痛苦加入讨论。
I guess I would start by saying something from the movie Jaws-- I'd be worried a lot less if I thought you were worried a little more. The idea that you've used the word "consistent" to describe Donald Trump is, to me, ludicrous. Have you followed Donald Trump's business career? He has been an emphatic, full-throated supporter of government intervention. He has used those levers to get buildings built and to get bankruptcies disposed of. I don't know what--
我想我会从电影《大白鲨》里的一句台词开始说起——如果我认为你们再多担心一点，我就不会这么担心了。你用“一贯”这个词来形容唐纳德·特朗普，在我看来是荒谬的。你关注过唐纳德·特朗普的商业生涯吗？他一直是一个坚定、直言不讳的政府干预支持者。他利用这些杠杆来建造建筑物并处置破产问题。我不知道什么——
Rob is now curled into a little ball, I think.
我想罗伯现在蜷缩成了一个小球。
I retreat to my Never-Trump safe room.
我撤退到我的“反特朗普”安全屋里去了。
Zoe and I invited Rob Long into our studio to talk about how Donald Trump is changing the party. Rob Long says that it's pained him, hearing his friends say we have to win this year.
佐伊和我邀请罗伯·朗来到我们的演播室，谈谈唐纳德·特朗普是如何改变这个政党的。罗伯·朗说，听到他的朋友们说我们今年必须赢，这让他很痛苦。
Winning under those principles is really not worth it. I mean, win? Win and what? Raise tariffs 25% on imports? It's crazy. That's a crazy, crazy, crazy ignorant idea. And I think that Trump isn't even-- I mean, this thing on the bus, the audio on the bus, I mean, anyone who was surprised by that? I mean, give me a break. We knew he talks like that.
为了那些原则而获胜根本不值得。我是说，赢？赢了又怎样？对进口商品加征25%的关税？这太疯狂了。那是一个疯狂、疯狂、极其无知的想法。而且我认为特朗普甚至——我是说，那件巴士上的事，巴士上的音频，有谁对此感到惊讶吗？得了吧。我们知道他就是那样说话的。
To me, it's more like, at any point, Trump could have chosen to be a big person. He could have chosen. He could have just sat there in Trump Tower and said, "You know, I'm going to have a speech about how great Martin Luther King was, and how great America is, and how we all need to come together. I'm going to give a big-- somebody write me a big speech. I don't know the words. You give me the words, but I want a big, big, big speech."
对我来说，更多的是，在任何时候，特朗普本可以选择成为一个大度的人。他本可以选择。他本可以坐在特朗普大厦里说：“你知道吗，我要发表一个演讲，讲讲马丁·路德·金有多伟大，美国有多伟大，我们都需要团结起来。我要发表一个盛大的——有人帮我写个盛大的演讲稿。我不知道该用什么词。你给我提供词句，但我想要一个盛大、盛大、盛大的演讲。”
He could have done that. It would have cost him zero. He just chose each time the small route. And I just find that offensive. I just am offended by that. I think it's a great, great, great gift to run for president. It's a great gift to be an American. And for him to do that and to treat it that way, callously, that's wrong.
他本可以那样做。那对他来说零成本。但他每次都选择了小家子气的路线。我发现这令人反感。我被这种行为冒犯了。我认为竞选总统是一个巨大、巨大、巨大的天赋。成为美国人是一份伟大的礼物。而他这样做，并且如此冷漠地对待它，那是错误的。
But it's not just Trump. For all three Ricochet guys, what's disturbing is the issues that Republican voters are abandoning this year and the issues they've decided to move towards. In one of their episodes, the Ricochet hosts had this Republican political guy, Avik Roy, who's been a policy adviser to Marco Rubio, and Rick Perry, and Mitt Romney during their presidential campaigns. I interviewed him too. Roy has gotten some attention in the press for saying how dismayed he is that traditional Republican ideals have been cast aside this year. He says the issue these days that really animates Republican voters is immigration. What the party is about is racial resentment.
但这不仅仅是特朗普的问题。对于《Ricochet》的所有三个家伙来说，令人不安的是共和党选民今年正在放弃的议题，以及他们决定转向的议题。在他们的一集节目中，主持人请来了共和党政治人物阿维克·罗伊（Avik Roy），他曾在马可·鲁比奥（Marco Rubio）、里克·佩里（Rick Perry）和米特·罗姆尼（Mitt Romney）的总统竞选中担任政策顾问。我也采访了他。罗伊因表达他对传统共和党理想今年被抛弃的失望而受到媒体关注。他说，如今真正激励共和党选民的议题是移民。这个政党的核心是种族怨恨。
What I saw the Republican Party becoming was a vehicle for the grievance of disaffected whites who believed that the Republican Party should be an interest group for whites.
我所看到的共和党正在变成一种工具，用来发泄那些不满的白人的怨气，他们认为共和党应该成为白人的利益集团。
Do you feel like this is your party, the party that you see now?
你觉得这是你的政党吗，你现在看到的这个政党？
No, I don't. And I don't know if I consider myself a Republican anymore. I think the Republican Party is a lost cause. I don't think the Republican party is capable of fixing itself, because the people who are most passionate about voting Republican today are the Trump voters. And what politician is going to want to throw those voters away to attract some unknown coalition of the future?
不，我不觉得。我不知道我是否还认为自己是共和党人。我认为共和党已经无药可救了。我不认为共和党有能力自我修复，因为今天最热衷于投票给共和党的人就是特朗普的选民。有哪个政客会愿意为了吸引某种未知的未来联盟而抛弃这些选民呢？
This is the big question for all these guys- what's their party going to be after November 8? What's it going to stand for? Again, here's Rob Long.
这对他们所有人来说都是一个大问题——11月8日之后他们的党会变成什么样？它会代表什么？再次声明，这是罗伯·朗的观点。
Look, everybody I know who's in my position is just sitting there, waiting and seeing. We're going to sit and wait and see. December 1, we'll probably start climbing out from the smoking ruin and say, "anybody else alive around here?" It'll be like The Walking Dead, right? We're going to try to come up with bands of people and walk across the country, and just not get ourselves killed or eaten, and hook up with people we think are not insane or horrible or in some way murderous. That's exactly what it's going to be like.
听着，我认识的处于我这个位置的人都在坐着，静观其变。我们要坐等观察。12月1日，我们可能会开始从冒烟的废墟中爬出来，说：“这儿还有活人吗？”这就像《行尸走肉》，对吧？我们将尝试组织成群结队的人，穿越全国，只是为了不让自己被杀掉或吃掉，并与那些我们认为不疯狂、不恐怖或不至于残暴的人结盟。情况就是这样。
The problem for old school traditional Republicans like Rob Long and Avik Roy is that all the things that they saw as the central tenants of their party-- free trade, cut entitlements, shrink government- what they learned this election is that their fellow Republicans don't care about that stuff. Well, lots of them don't, anyway. The ones who voted for Trump in the primaries, which was 45% of Republican primary votes, what those people voted for instead was "pull the drawbridge up," "close the borders," "protect American jobs." Very different from the old Republican values. Rob Long says that after the election, the two sides are going to have to rethink what the party is.
对于像罗伯·朗和阿维克·罗伊这样的老派传统共和党人来说，问题在于他们视为政党核心信条的所有东西——自由贸易、削减福利、精简政府——他们在这次选举中了解到，他们的共和党同仁并不关心这些。好吧，至少很多人不关心。那些在初选中投票给特朗普的人（占共和党初选票数的45%），这些人投票支持的是“拉起吊桥”、“关闭边境”、“保护美国就业”。这与共和党的旧价值观截然不同。罗伯·朗说，选举后，双方将不得不重新思考这个党究竟是什么。
It is going to be a fight for the soul of their party, right? Those two groups cannot occupy the party at the same time.
这将是一场为这个党的灵魂而战的战斗，对吧？那两个群体不能同时占据这个党。
And does rethinking mean that it makes you think "oh, well, maybe let's get rid of the entitlement reform. Let's not argue for cutting Medicare and Social Security. People don't like that."
重新思考是否意味着让你觉得“哦，好吧，也许让我们放弃福利改革吧。让我们不要再争论削减医疗保险和社会保障了。人们不喜欢那样。”
Yeah, but the whole point of being Republican is that you're supposed to say things that people don't like but that are true anyway. Like, nobody wants to put missiles in West Germany, but that's how you beat back the Soviet menace. Nobody wants to say to a 35- or 30-year-old wage earner, "by the way, your retirement age is going to be 73 or 75. So just take care of yourself or don't. But in any case, you better save something." Nobody wants to say those things. Nobody really wants to be the party of that.
是的，但共和党的全部意义在于，你应该说出人们不喜欢但却是正确的事。就像没人想在西德部署导弹，但那是你击败苏联威胁的方式。没人想对一个35岁或30岁的工薪族说：“顺便说一句，你的退休年龄将是73或75岁。所以照顾好你自己，或者别管了。但无论如何，你最好存点钱。”没人想说这些话。没人真的想成为这样一个党的成员。
Yeah.
是的。
But that's what being a Republican means-- you're supposed to say the stuff that's true, even if nobody wants to hear it.
但这就是共和党的意义所在——你应该说出真实的话，即使没人想听。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. . I'm Ira Glass. The fact is, this fight over what the Republican Party is going to be, it's already happening. It's not waiting for the election. It's happening right now. The battlegrounds are all over the country. And that's what our program is about today. We take you to one town. It's one of the front lines.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。事实是，这场关于共和党将成为什么的斗争已经在发生了。它不需要等到选举。它现在正在发生。战场遍布全国。这就是我们今天节目要讨论的内容。我们带你走进一个小镇。这是前线之一。
Meanwhile, in Washington, like right now, the Republican leadership, well, for months Zoe's been saying that, basically, they seem to be going through the same thing the Ricochet guys are. They're looking at their own party and they're saying, "wait. Is that us? Like, what's happening?"
与此同时，在华盛顿，就在现在，共和党领导层，嗯，几个月来佐伊一直在说，基本上，他们似乎正在经历与《Ricochet》那些家伙相同的事情。他们看着自己的党，然后说：“等等。那是我们吗？这是怎么回事？”
So you look at somebody like Paul Ryan, Speaker of the House, right, or Reince Priebus, who's head of the RNC, and even somebody like John McCain. It's like they've been fighting this battle for their ideals to run the country. And they thought they had this big band of voters behind them. And then, with Paul Ryan in particular, it feels like he just turned around and he's like, "oh, my god. Nobody's there."
所以你看看像保罗·瑞安（Paul Ryan，众议院议长）这样的人，或者里恩斯·普里巴斯（Reince Priebus，共和党全国委员会主席），甚至像约翰·麦凯恩（John McCain）这样的人。就像他们一直在为他们治理国家的理想而战斗。他们以为他们身后有这群庞大的选民。然后，特别是对于保罗·瑞安，感觉他刚转过身来，就像是“天哪。没人在这儿。”
Right, Republican voters rejected those ideas when they voted for Trump. But then Ryan is still going around, trying to sell them on cutting Social Security and the kind of traditional Republican stuff, which Ryan has put together into a plan he calls "A Better Way."
是的，共和党选民在投票支持特朗普时拒绝了那些想法。但瑞安仍然到处推销削减社会保障和那种传统的共和党那一套，瑞安将这些整理成了一个他称之为“更好的方式”（A Better Way）的计划。
Yeah, in this election, people don't want that.
是的，这次选举中，人们不想要那个。
Also, at the personal level-- Ryan is this super disciplined guy who exercises, and he's careful about his diet, and he's a policy nerd, and he's polite, and he's kind of proper. And he's watching his voters cheering this guy who's the total opposite.
此外，在个人层面上——瑞安是个超级自律的人，他锻炼，注意饮食，是个政策书呆子，很有礼貌，也相当正派。而他正在看着他的选民为一个完全相反的家伙欢呼。
It seems incredibly lonely for Ryan. And it looks incredibly sad, and it looks very, very painful.
这对于瑞安来说似乎非常孤独。而且看起来非常悲伤，看起来非常、非常痛苦。
And for months, Zoe, you have been saying that these Republican leaders just seemed like tragic figures to you, like somebody should write a tragic opera.
几个月来，佐伊，你一直说这些共和党领导人对你来说就像悲剧人物，好像应该有人为他们写一部悲剧歌剧。
Someone should.
确实应该。
As you know, because of your wish, we considered commissioning a tragic opera about Paul Ryan or Reince Priebus.
如你所知，因为你的愿望，我们考虑委托创作一部关于保罗·瑞安或里恩斯·普里巴斯的悲剧歌剧。
Mhm.
嗯。
And then we decided as a staff--
然后我们作为员工决定——
You preferred a musical. A musical is more fun than an opera.
你更喜欢音乐剧。音乐剧比歌剧更有趣。
That is correct. And with that in mind, I am pleased to present now, not a musical but a song, a world premiere by Robert Lopez and Kristen Anderson-Lopez. They did the songs in Frozen. And basically we told them that Paul Ryan has all kinds of feelings that he can't express publicly right now, but they are the sort of feelings that a person might sing. Could they help us imagine those feelings? Neil Patrick Harris sings the part of Paul Ryan.
没错。考虑到这一点，我很高兴现在呈现的不是一部音乐剧，而是一首歌，由罗伯特·洛佩兹（Robert Lopez）和克里斯汀·安德森-洛佩兹（Kristen Anderson-Lopez）创作的世界首演作品。他们创作了《冰雪奇缘》的歌曲。我们基本上告诉他们，保罗·瑞安现在有各种无法公开表达的感受，但它们是那种一个人可能会唱出来的感受。他们能帮我们想象这些感受吗？尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯（Neil Patrick Harris）演唱保罗·瑞安的部分。
(SINGING) I knew some time ago you didn't want what I could give you anymore. I knew some time ago this was not the party that it was for us before. The truth sets in but the dream persists. I don't believe you're all white nationalists. It hurt to see you running to him. I hope in time you'll see right through him.
（演唱）我早就知道你不再想要我能给你的东西了。我早就知道这不是我们以前所在的党派了。真相显现，但梦想依旧。我不相信你们都是白人民族主义者。看到你们投奔他让我很受伤。我希望将来你能看穿他。
And I'll be there when the nightmare has ended. Yes, I'll be there in the light of day. Turn your back on that troll you befriended. Then come on back to me when you're ready for a better way. I know he's what you want. I know he says the things that make your passions flare. I know he's fun and all. Maybe I'm no fun, but it's because I truly care. It's only for your sake that I endorsed. I'm sure you could tell it was completely forced. Now the guy is calling me a wussy. I wish I could grab him by the lapels and tell him--
当噩梦结束时我会在这里。是的，我会在白昼的光芒中在这里。背弃那个你结交的巨魔吧。然后在你准备好迎接更好的方式时回到我身边。我知道这就是你想要的。我知道他说的话让你们的激情迸发。我知道他很有趣。也许我很无趣，那是因为我真心在乎。我只因为你才背书。我相信你看得出来那是完全被强迫的。现在那家伙叫我软蛋。我真想抓住他的衣领告诉他——
I'll be there to pick up all the pieces. I'll be there, no matter what they say. Cut him loose and don't let him near your nieces. Then come on back to me, because you'll be ready for a better way. Cut Medicare. A better way! More fossil fuels! A better way! Social Security privatization! Get the poor off welfare for good. Defund Planned Parenthood. Gay marriage, abortion, and gun control are all unconstitutional. Your conservative ideals, no spending tastes as good as a balanced budget feels. And I'll be there with policies a plenty. Yes, I'll be there rising above the fray. You'll see me one fine day in 2020. At least, I hope you will. God, I hope there's still a better way.
我会在这里收拾残局。无论他们说什么我都会在这里。甩掉他，别让他靠近你的侄女。然后在你准备好迎接更好的方式时回到我身边。削减医疗保险。更好的方式！更多的化石燃料。更好的方式！社会保障私有化。让穷人永久脱离福利。取消对计划生育协会的资助。同性婚姻、堕胎和枪支管制都是违宪的。你的保守理想，没有什么是比预算平衡的感觉更让人满足的了。我会带着充足的政策在这里。是的，我会在这里升华。在2020年的美好一天你会见到我。至少，我希望如此。上帝，我希望还有更好的方式。
Neil Patrick Harris. The orchestrator and music director for our song was Stephen Oremus. Which leads us to Act 1, Party in the USA.
尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯。这首歌的编曲和音乐总监是斯蒂芬·奥雷姆斯（Stephen Oremus）。这把我们带到了第一幕，美国派对。
One way to track the changes in the Republican Party and understand the split inside the party is to look at immigration. Obviously, it was Donald Trump's biggest issue during the primaries. There was the wall. There was the ban on Muslims. He even opposed certain forms of legal immigration, like the H-1b visa program.
追踪共和党变化并理解党内分裂的一种方法是关注移民。显然，这是唐纳德·特朗普在初选期间最大的议题。有那堵墙。有针对穆斯林的禁令。他甚至反对某些形式的合法移民，比如H-1B签证计划。
Remember that guy, Avik Roy, the one you heard a little earlier who advised Marco Rubio and Rick Perry and Mitt Romney during their presidential campaigns? Avik Roy believes that immigration is the issue that is deciding Republican presidential primaries now. He says that he watched two of his candidates, Rick Perry and Marco Rubio, get into situations where Republicans simply would not forgive them because of their positions on immigration. They were seen as soft. Rubio would get booed at grassroots events. Perry went from being the frontrunner in the Republican primaries, back in 2011. He was far ahead of the other candidates, in fact, but got knocked out of first place after a debate on September 22 that year, where Romney attacked Perry on this issue, and Perry was booed.
还记得那个阿维克·罗伊吗，就是你之前听到的那个曾在马可·鲁比奥、里克·佩里和米特·罗姆尼的总统竞选中提供建议的人？阿维克·罗伊认为移民是目前决定共和党总统初选的议题。他说他看着他的两位候选人，里克·佩里和马可·鲁比奥，陷入了困境，因为共和党人根本不会因为他们在移民问题上的立场而原谅他们。他们被视为软弱。鲁比奥在基层活动中会被嘘。佩里在2011年时曾是共和党初选的领跑者。事实上，他远远领先于其他候选人，但在那年9月22日的辩论后，他跌出了第一名，当时罗姆尼在这个议题上攻击了佩里，而佩里遭到了嘘声。
The crowd booed, and overnight, Rick Perry went from first to fifth in the race. What was remarkable about that was that Rick Perry in every other way was a rock-ribbed conservative, on every other issue. But because of that one issue, immigration, the equation flipped and the voters went with Romney over Perry. He was sunk.
人群发出了嘘声，一夜之间，里克·佩里在竞选中从第一掉到了第五。令人瞩目的是，里克·佩里在每个其他议题上都是坚定的保守派。但因为那一个议题，移民，等式翻转了，选民选择了罗姆尼而不是佩里。他沉没了。
So immigration is this urgent, emotional issue for much of the Republican Party these days. But why? The facts on the ground on this issue are not changing dramatically. There is not a big surge of new immigrants into the country all of a sudden. As we talked about last week on our show, illegal immigration has been flat since 2009. Legal immigration has fallen in the last decade. So why is this the issue now? Why not the deficit, or the slow economic recovery, or the squeeze on the middle class, or taxes? Like, why a wall?
所以移民是这些天共和党大部分人关心的紧急、情感议题。但为什么呢？这个议题上的事实并没有发生剧烈变化。并没有突然出现大量新移民涌入这个国家。正如我们上周在节目中谈到的，非法移民自2009年以来一直持平。合法移民在过去十年中有所下降。那么为什么现在是这个议题呢？为什么不是赤字，或者缓慢的经济复苏，或者中产阶级受到的挤压，或者税收？比如，为什么是一堵墙？
All this year, when our producer Zoe Chace was at Trump rallies and Republican events around the country, she would ask voters why is this your issue? Did you lose your job to a foreigner? Do you live in a place that's been negatively impacted by immigrants? And people were like, no. It's hard to understand how this became the issue for so many people this year. And then, in July, when Zoe was at the Republican National Convention, she met somebody. And she heard about a place that gave her a better sense of why.
今年一整年，当我们的制片人佐伊·蔡斯在全国各地的特朗普集会和共和党活动中时，她会问选民为什么这是你们关心的议题？你因为外国人丢了工作吗？你住的地方受到移民的负面影响了吗？人们回答说，没有。很难理解这怎么成了今年对那么多人来说的议题。然后在7月，当佐伊在共和党全国代表大会时，她遇到一个人。她听到了一个地方，给了她更好的理由。
The person is Bobby Benson. The place is Minnesota. I first met Bobby at a barbecue at the convention, right outside the arena. He was drinking beers at a picnic table with the rest of the Minnesota delegation. And he'd brought along his best friend, Scott. These two grew up together in Hugo, Minnesota.
这个人是鲍比·本森（Bobby Benson）。这个地方是明尼苏达州。我第一次见到鲍比是在代表大会上的一次烧烤会上，就在竞技场外面。他和明尼苏达代表团的其他人一起在野餐桌上喝啤酒。他还带上了他最好的朋友斯科特。这两个人在明尼苏达州的雨果一起长大。
They used to have similar views but they've split recently. Scott's saying stuff that drives Bobby crazy. For instance, they disagree on that thing that's splitting the party, the main plank of Trump's platform-- immigration. Scott addresses the whole picnic table.
他们曾经有相似的观点，但最近分道扬镳了。斯科特说的话让鲍比抓狂。例如，他们在那个分裂党的议题上存在分歧，即特朗普政纲的主要内容——移民。斯科特对着整张野餐桌发表意见。
The wall's coming. And who's going to pay for it, everybody? Mexico!
墙要来了。谁来买单，各位？墨西哥！
Your friend just choked on his beer.
你的朋友刚才被啤酒呛到了。
I know.
我知道。
Bobby basically does a spit take. He's anti-wall.
鲍比基本上做出了喷水的样子。他是反墙派。
I guess I just believe that America is for everyone. And the symbolism of a wall is just-- it's not me.
我想我只是相信美国是属于每个人的。而墙的象征意义只是——那不是我。
Scott, Bobby points out, had a wall around his house when they were kids. So maybe that's why he loves it so much.
鲍比指出，斯科特小时候房子周围有一堵墙。所以也许这就是他如此喜欢它的原因。
You should have seen this guy's house growing up. He had a nine-foot fence. I'm not lying at all. A nine-foot wooden fence. You couldn't even see between the slats. I'm not lying at all!
你应该看看这家伙小时候的房子。他有一道九英尺高的栅栏。我一点也没撒谎。九英尺高的木栅栏。你甚至看不见板条之间的空隙。我一点也没撒谎！
They just wanted us to be safe and secure.
他们只是想让我们安全有保障。
Bobby's very Minnesotan to me, what I have in my head as Minnesotan, anyway. He's got this round, pleasant face. He can't handle hot sauce or anything spicy. He actually says "I don't like anything with flavor." And he's really, really nice. He doesn't like to disagree or call people out. This has put him in a hard position lately. The GOP just wrote "build a wall" into its platform. Which means Bobby's views on immigration are in no way represented at this convention. It's uncomfortable for him, because he loves being a Republican, like really loves it. He's got school spirit. This should be a fun party for him, but he's feeling weird about it.
鲍比在我看来非常明尼苏达，至少我脑海中明尼苏达人的形象是这样。他有一张圆圆的、讨人喜欢的脸。他受不了辣酱或任何辛辣的东西。他实际上说“我不喜欢任何有风味的东西”。而且他非常、非常好。他不喜欢反驳或公开指责别人。这让他最近处境艰难。共和党刚刚把“建一堵墙”写进了政纲。这意味着鲍比对移民的看法在这个代表大会上完全没有得到体现。这让他感到不舒服，因为他喜欢成为共和党人，真的是非常喜欢。他有学校精神。这本应对他来说是一个有趣的聚会，但他对它感到很奇怪。
Bobby's friends go into the arena. We stay outside and watch Newt Gingrich on this huge television screen. He's scrupulously listing all the terrorist attacks committed by Muslims over the past 37 days.
鲍比的朋友进入了竞技场。我们留在外面看巨大电视屏幕上的纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）。他正在逐一列出穆斯林在过去37天里犯下的所有恐怖袭击。
Let me refresh your memory.
让我刷新一下你们的记忆。
And that's when Bobby spills what's bothering him. He's like, "speaking of Muslims, there is a large Somali population in St. Cloud, Minnesota," right near where Bobby lives.
就在那时，鲍比说出了困扰他的事情。他说，“说到穆斯林，圣克劳德（St. Cloud）有一个庞大的索马里人口，”就在鲍比住的地方附近。
And people are furious. It's insane up there. I feel so bad.
人们很愤怒。那里的情况太疯狂了。我感到很难过。
He's dodging the mic at first, but then he tells me this upsetting story. A few months ago, Bobby was at an Applebee's in Coon Rapids. It's like an hour away from St. Cloud. And this hate crime unfolded right in front of him.
他起初躲避麦克风，但后来他告诉我这个令人不安的故事。几个月前，鲍比在库恩拉皮兹（Coon Rapids）的一家Applebee's餐厅。离圣克劳德大概一小时路程。这个仇恨犯罪就在他面前展开了。
This woman, this-- I don't know if she was Somali-- this African woman was with two of her friends and their children, just minding their business. And they happened to be speaking Somali or whatever language. And this other white woman and her husband took offense to it and just started cursing at them in the restaurant, like "speak English," "you're awful," this, that. And one thing leads to another.
这个女人，这个——我不知道她是不是索马里人——这个非洲女人和她的两个朋友以及孩子们在一起，只是在忙自己的事。她们正好在说索马里语或其他什么语言。另一个白人女人和她的丈夫对此感到被冒犯，就开始在餐馆里咒骂她们，比如“说英语”、“你们真糟糕”，诸如此类。事情就这样升级了。
And the management in Applebee's, great people, they kicked the angry couple out. And they're working on that. And the woman has one of those big beer glasses and just sloshes it in her face. And again, strictly because a group of people were not speaking English. And then she sets her drink down. They start walking out, and she picks up her drink and smashes it in the woman's face. And then just pandemonium erupts. The kids are crying.
Applebee's的管理人员，很棒的人，把那对愤怒的夫妇赶了出去。他们正在处理这件事。而那个女人手里拿着一个大啤酒杯，直接泼在她脸上。同样，纯粹是因为一群人在说非英语的语言。然后她把酒杯放下。他们开始走出去，她拿起酒杯砸在那女人的脸上。接着骚乱爆发了。孩子们在哭。
The African woman's face was cut up and bloody from the glass. The incident made the news. Lots of people heard about it and talked about it. What happened that night was horrifying enough, but what really started upsetting Bobby was the conversation about it afterwards. Some people around him were siding with the woman who smashed the glass, not the victim.
那个非洲女人的脸被玻璃划破流血了。这件事上了新闻。很多人听说了并议论纷纷。那天晚上发生的事情已经够恐怖了，但真正让鲍比感到不安的是事后的对话。他身边的一些人竟然站在砸酒杯的那个女人一边，而不是受害者这边。
Talking to other people about it, they say simple things like "well, you know, she could have just been speaking English." And it's like, "oh, well, they could've just left well enough alone." It's like, no!
和其他人谈论这件事时，他们会说简单的话，比如“好吧，你知道，她本可以只说英语的。”就好像，“哦，好吧，她们本可以息事宁人的。”好像，不！
Every time I asked Bobby to explain who exactly was talking this way, Bobby would squirm in his seat and hold his breath like a kid scared to tattle tale. Like he was being disloyal.
每次我请鲍比解释究竟是谁在这样说话时，鲍比就会在座位上扭动，屏住呼吸，就像一个害怕告密的孩子。就像他不忠诚一样。
I have to choose my words very carefully. A lot of them are my friends and they're like good people. I know people who-- I'm trying to think of the most-- no, well, can we pause this for a second.
我必须非常小心地选择我的措辞。他们很多是我的朋友，他们就像好人。我认识那些——我在想最——不，好吧，我们可以暂停一下吗。
Basically, he doesn't want other Republicans in St. Cloud, Minnesota, to think he thinks they're being racist. These are his friends and family he's talking about. He let me start recording again.
基本上，他不想让圣克劳德的其他共和党人认为他觉得他们在种族歧视。他说的是他的朋友和家人。他让我重新开始录音。
I don't know. You understand where I'm at, the precarious, wanting to be-- I definitely don't want to have it out there like, "look, this is Bobby Benson saying these people are wrong." Even though they're wrong, I don't--
我不知道。你明白我的处境，那种不稳定的，想要——我绝对不想让外界认为，“看，这是鲍比·本森在说这些人错了。”尽管他们错了，我不想——
And just why?
那为什么？
Because I want to be part of steering the party, at least at a local level, to a better place. You can't change things if you're not at the table.
因为我想参与引导这个党，至少在地方层面，走向更好的方向。如果你不在谈判桌上，你就无法改变事情。
And that's what Bobby wants to do. He wants to change things in his party. I've been looking to understand better how Republicans were dividing over this immigration stuff. And here were Bobby and Scott and this whole city of Republicans who used to mostly agree on stuff. And now these Republicans have ended up on opposite sides of a wall.
这就是鲍比想做的。他想改变他党内的事情。我一直在努力更好地理解共和党人是如何因为这些移民问题而分裂的。这就是鲍比和斯科特以及这整个城市的共和党人，他们过去大多在事情上意见一致。现在这些共和党人最终站在了墙的两端。
Bobby told me he started freaking out about this exactly one year ago. It was in July of 2015 at a town hall meeting in St. Cloud.
鲍比告诉我，他是在一年前就开始为此感到恐慌的。那是2015年7月在圣克劳德的一次市政厅会议上。
And I wish all of you guys would give him a big hand here at Aces.
我希望你们所有人都能在Aces给这位大人物一点掌声。
This is Bobby's local congressman, Tom Emmer. They're at the Aces Bar in downtown St. Cloud. The room is packed. People are squished in around the bar. This is one of many town halls Emmer does regularly all over the district. And it's going normally, a little awkwardly, till this guy says "I think most of us are here to find out how you feel about assimilation of immigrants." Assimilation of immigrants. The congressman is confused, so the questioner clarifies.
这是鲍比当地的国会议员汤姆·埃默（Tom Emmer）。他们在圣克劳德市中心的Aces酒吧。房间里挤满了人。人们在酒吧周围挤在一起。这是埃默定期在该区各地举行的众多市政厅会议之一。进展正常，有点尴尬，直到这个人说，“我想我们大多数人来这里是为了了解你对移民同化问题的看法。”移民同化。国会议员很困惑，所以提问者澄清了。
We did not ask for those Somalis. Nobody asked us if we, in St. Cloud, want those Somalis. And we understand that social groups, like the Lutheran social service and the Catholic charities, they're dumping them in areas like St. Cloud. OK, and so the question is, how many more are coming? We didn't ask for these people. Everybody that you read about is talking about this. So that is a main issue in this city. There is no control. The people have no control over any immigration. The mayor doesn't. I don't know.
我们没有要求那些索马里人。没人问过我们，在圣克劳德，我们是否想要那些索马里人。我们了解社会团体，比如路德会社会服务和天主教慈善机构，他们把他们倾倒在像圣克劳德这样的地区。好的，所以问题是，还要来多少？我们没有要求这些人。你读到的每个人都在谈论这个。所以这是这个城市的一个主要议题。没有控制。人们对任何移民都没有控制权。市长也没有。我不知道。
Congressman Emmer is like, what are you even talking about it? If someone's here legally, you don't get a say in whether they come into your city. And he fires a warning shot at the implicit racism here against Somalis, as if to say "don't go further down this road, you guys."
埃默议员就像，你到底在说什么？如果有人合法在这里，你对他们是否进入你的城市没有发言权。他向这里针对索马里人的隐含种族主义发出了一声警告，似乎是在说，“别再走这条路了，伙计们。”
And if you're asking me how I feel about immigrant populations who are in this country legally, and who are actually trying to find a better way for themselves and their families, I support it wholeheartedly. I mean, the Germans had the same problem when they came over. The Polish had the problem. The Chinese had the problem.
如果你问我如何看待在这个国家合法存在，并且确实在为自己和家人寻求更好生活方式的移民人口，我全心全意支持。我是说，德国人过来时也遇到了同样的问题。波兰人遇到了这个问题。中国人遇到了这个问题。
They did it on their own, though.
但他们是靠自己做到的。
We have a different problem. They didn't come to subvert the Constitution.
我们有不同的问题。他们不是来颠覆宪法的。
You're not addressing the idea that they're not being assimilated. The other--
你没有解决他们没有被同化的想法。其他——
I'm going to tell you, the Somalis, according to the measurements that have been used over time, are some of the fastest-assimilating populations that we've had.
我要告诉你，根据长期使用的测量方法，索马里人是我们拥有的融合最快的人口之一。
[GROANING]
（呻吟）
Oh, you gotta be kidding me.
哦，你一定是在开玩笑。
There are Somalis in the room too.
房间里也有索马里人。
I hear all the time the word "assimilation." I feel myself assimilated.
我一直听到“同化”这个词。我觉得我自己被同化了。
I speak English. I have a job. I have a family. I drive the same streets every day, just like you. What's the thing that's missing? You should not be afraid of Muslims here.
我会说英语。我有工作。我有家庭。我和你们一样每天开着同样的街道。缺少什么东西？你不应该在这里害怕穆斯林。
If you guys have any questions, anything to talk about, come to us. We'll answer all your questions. We will address your fears. But I don't think there's nothing we have to fear in America.
如果你们有任何问题，任何要谈的，来找我们。我们会回答你们所有的问题。我们会解决你们的恐惧。但我认为在美国我们没什么可害怕的。
Some people in the room don't buy it. They push back and demand a vote on refugees. Emmer pushes back too.
房间里有些人不买账。他们反驳并要求对难民进行投票。埃默也进行了反击。
I'm going to say it out loud-- when you move to a community, as long as you are here legally, I am very sorry but you don't get to slam the gate behind you and tell nobody else that they're welcome. That's not the way this country works. And if we're going to talk about--
我要大声说出来——当你搬到一个社区时，只要你是合法在这里的，我很抱歉但你不能关上大门，告诉其他人他们不受欢迎。这个国家不是那样运作的。如果我们谈论——
I didn't think it was a problem until somebody I knew really well, because they got upset--
我没觉得这有什么问题，直到我认识的一个人真的非常，因为他们很心烦——
This is Tom Emmer talking about that night.
这是汤姆·埃默在谈论那天晚上。
They said "it sounds like you're telling us. You're not listening to us."
他们说“听起来你在告诉我们。你没有听我们的。”
We also work hard, and we also pay our taxes. And we also have kids to raise and go to school. And there's a huge economic burden placed on us now. And I think part of the fear-- some of you talked about our fear-- is that we don't feel in control of what's happening in our city. It is out of our control. Where is our say on what happens to our schools? I don't know that you've heard us. I feel you told us.
我们也努力工作，我们也纳税。我们也有孩子要抚养和上学。现在我们背负着巨大的经济负担。我认为恐惧的一部分——你们有些人谈到了我们的恐惧——是我们觉得对城市里发生的事情没有控制权。这超出了我们的控制。我们在学校发生的事情上有什么发言权？我不认为你听到了我们的声音。我觉得你在告诉我们。
[APPLAUSE]
（掌声）
And I thought I had been listening all night. So I stopped, because then I thought, "this is a problem, because this person is not that way."
我以为我整晚都在听。所以我停了下来，因为那时我想，“这是一个问题，因为这个人不是那样的人。”
Say what you mean, "this person is not that way." What does that mean?
把你的意思说清楚，“这个人不是那样的人。”那是什么意思？
They're reasonable. They listen. They're compassionate. They have definite, strong views, right? Their views are much like mine. I've known them for a long time. And this person was clearly frustrated, so I stopped. And I said, "I apologize. What is it that you would like your congressman to do?"
他们很理智。他们听取意见。他们很有同情心。他们有明确、强烈的观点，对吧？他们的观点和我很像。我认识他们很久了。而这个人显然很沮丧，所以我停了下来。我说，“我很抱歉。你想要你的国会议员做什么？”
You're our only chance.
你是我们唯一的机会。
For what, Sue? What is it that you want?
为了什么，苏？你想要什么？
OK,
好的，
What is it that want from me?
你想要我做什么？
I think I speak for a lot of people. I think the city of St. Cloud needs a breather. And we need to assimilate with the people that are--
我想我代表了很多人。我认为圣克劳德市需要喘口气。我们需要与那些——的人同化。
What does that mean? What does that mean?
那是什么意思？那是什么意思？
It's a break on the influx for a period of time, so we could take a little breather.
这是一段时期的流入停顿，好让我们喘口气。
Here's the thing, your last statement, though, "take a little breather."
关键是，你最后的声明，“稍微喘口气”。
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
（零星掌声）
You  guys, could you just hold on. Say it out loud. Are you suggesting that no more immigrants should be allowed to come to St. Cloud?
你们，你们能稍微等一下吗。大声说出来。你是建议不允许更多的移民来圣克劳德了吗？
A moratorium for  a short time.
一个短时间的暂停。
For the whole United States!
整个美国！
The whole United States, yes.
整个美国，是的。
All right. All right, here's the thing. All I can do is respond as open and honest as I can, Sue. That's not something that I can do. That's not something that our constitution says that we do with people who are--
好吧。好吧，关键是这样的。我能做的就是尽可能坦诚地回应，苏。那不是我能做的事情。那不是我们的宪法规定我们对待那些——的人所做的事情。
That was the first time that I think I realized that even good people, really good people, because I know this person. This person is not a xenophobe, not a racist. I know this person for several years.
那是我第一次意识到，即使是好人，非常好的好人，因为我认识这个人。这个人不是仇外者，不是种族主义者。我认识这个人好几年了。
This was a big moment for Tom Emmer. This is when he understood two surprising things. First, his voters want a ban on Muslims. They want no more Somali immigrants coming to their town. And second, the voters who want this, they aren't fringe weirdos. These are people he knows, and likes, and respects.
这对汤姆·埃默来说是一个重大时刻。这是他理解了两个令人惊讶的事情的时候。第一，他的选民想要禁止穆斯林。他们不想再有索马里移民来到他们的城镇。第二，想要这样做的选民，他们不是边缘怪胎。这些人是他认识、喜欢和尊重的。
Some background here. There are a lot more Somalis in town than there used to be, over a short period of time. 15 years ago, there were only a handful of Somali residents in St. Cloud. Now there are approximately 10,000, about 5% of the St. Cloud metro population, which is 190,000. But still, almost 90% of St. Cloud is white, majority Catholic or Lutheran. It was and still is, relatively speaking, a monolithic place. People up there are always saying this thing. "Yeah, this place used to be called White Cloud, because it was so white." A place that was closed off and suspicious of outsiders. Now there's this whole big new group of Somalis there too.
这里有一些背景。城里的索马里人比以前多了很多，在很短的一段时间内。15年前，圣克劳德只有少数索马里居民。现在大约有10,000人，约占圣克劳德大都会人口190,000人的5%。但即便如此，圣克劳德近90%是白人，大多数是天主教徒或路德教徒。它曾经是，现在仍然是一个相对单一的地方。那里的人总是说那件事。“是的，这个地方过去被称为‘白云’，因为它太白了。”一个封闭且对局外人怀疑的地方。现在那里也有了一大群索马里人。
The reason Somalis came to St. Cloud is because there was civil war and famine in Somalia 25 years ago, which forced people into refugee camps, mostly in Kenya. The US government contracts with different non-profits that specialize in refugee resettlement. One of those is based in St. Paul, with an office in St. Cloud. And so a lot of the refugees end up in towns and cities in Minnesota after years spent in a camp.
索马里人来到圣克劳德的原因是25年前索马里发生了内战和饥荒，迫使人们进入难民营，大多是在肯尼亚。美国政府与专门从事难民安置的非营利组织签订合同。其中一个总部设在圣保罗，在圣克劳德设有办事处。所以很多难民在营地待了几年后最终来到了明尼苏达州的城镇和城市。
The Aces Bar town hall back in 2015 felt like a dress rehearsal of the anti-immigration feelings that fuel the Trump campaign. They were calling for the Muslim ban before he was.
2015年那次Aces酒吧市政厅会议感觉像是反移民情绪的预演，这助推了特朗普的竞选活动。在他之前，他们就在呼吁穆斯林禁令。
It was hard at first to get the long time residents of St. Cloud to talk about when did they first start to resent the growing population of Somalis in their town. It's a sensitive and awkward thing to confess. Some people hung up on me. I was thrown out of a meeting. I finally got some answers from Carol Rupar, head of the County Republican Party. She kindly did some research, printed out some old emails, and marched into Caribou Coffee with a stack of papers for our interview. She had a time line.
起初很难让圣克劳德的长住居民谈论他们是什么时候开始对城里日益增长的索马里人口产生怨恨的。这是一个敏感且尴尬的承认。有些人挂断了我的电话。我被赶出了会议。我终于从县共和党负责人卡罗尔·鲁帕（Carol Rupar）那里得到了一些答案。她好心地做了一些研究，打印出一些旧电子邮件，带着一叠文件走进卡里布咖啡馆接受我们的采访。她有一条时间线。
OK, well, I looked back at the first information that I had where this started. And I wrote down some thoughts on that.
好的，好吧，我回顾了我拥有的第一份信息，即这一切开始的时候。我就此写了一些想法。
Anti-refugee resettlement feeling.
反难民安置情绪。
When this whole thing started.
当这一切开始的时候。
According to Carol, it started in 2013, when the Islamic Center of St. Cloud tried to build this mosque/community center on Clearwater Road. This would be the fourth mosque in town, but the location was pretty controversial.
据卡罗尔说，这始于2013年，当时圣克劳德伊斯兰中心试图在清水路（Clearwater Road）上建造这个清真寺/社区中心。这将是镇上的第四座清真寺，但选址非常有争议。
It was a residential area, and that if they were going to build this big complex, that was going to change the whole-- I mean, there's a lot of traffic on Clearwater Road.
那是一个住宅区，如果他们要建造这个巨大的综合体，那将改变整个——我的意思是，清水路上的交通量很大。
Carol says she was not involved in opposing the mosque. She just knew some people who were. And those people formed a little group. They started calling themselves St. Cloud Citizens for Reasonable Zoning. And their complaints about it were, in part, all the normal things you hear in a zoning hearing-- traffic, congestion, "when I bought my house I didn't know about or want this kind of thing."
卡罗尔说她没有参与反对清真寺。她只是认识一些人。这些人组成了一个小团体。他们开始自称为“圣克劳德理性分区公民”。他们对它的抱怨，部分是你在分区听证会上听到的所有正常事情——交通、拥堵，“当我买房子时，我不知道或不想要这种事情。”
When the time came for the hearing, 300-odd people showed up at the city council meeting. It was a contentious night. Lots of Somalis and non-Somalis showed up, with big signs for and against.
当听证会时间到时，300多名民众出现在市议会会议上。那是一个充满争议的夜晚。许多索马里人和非索马里人带着支持和反对的大标语出现。
Please try to remember that the religion of this group is not the issue tonight.
请尽量记住，这个群体的宗教信仰不是今晚的议题。
Mr. President.
主席先生。
Sit down, please.
请坐下。
Your statement--
你的陈述——
If you would like to get in line, get in line. There's people waiting to speak.
如果你想排队，请排队。有人在等着发言。
The whole meeting was bitter enough that by the end of the night, the Islamic Center had withdrawn its proposal. In fact, they said they could find a better place for it. They did, and it exists today. Out of this organizing against the mosque, some people in this group decided to keep meeting. It was like after being in that room together and actually getting what they wanted, they realized, "oh, lots of us feel this way. We should stick together." St. Cloud Citizens for Reasonable Zoning morphed into another group-- Peace in St. Cloud.
整个会议非常痛苦，以至于到晚上结束时，伊斯兰中心撤回了他们的提案。事实上，他们说他们可以找到更好的地方。他们做到了，它今天存在。通过这种反对清真寺的组织活动，这个群体中的一些人决定继续会面。就像在那个房间里待在一起并确实得到了他们想要的东西后，他们意识到，“哦，我们很多人都有这种感觉。我们应该团结在一起。”圣克劳德理性分区公民演变成了另一个组织——“圣克劳德和平”。
And it was in July of 2015 when the situation started ramping up, according to what I could come up with.
据我所能找出的，情况是在2015年7月开始升级的。
Yeah.
是的。
And the residents in the area were feeling intimidated by the behavior. One quiet Sunday afternoon, there were a group of Somali women they described as a mini parade. On three occasions that afternoon, just parading through, making loud noises, taking pictures, and so that some of the little old ladies in the area got intimidated by that.
该地区的居民感到被这种行为恐吓了。在一个安静的周日下午，有一群索马里妇女，他们称之为“迷你游行”。那天下午有三次，只是游行经过，发出巨大的声音，拍照，以至于该地区的一些小老太太被吓到了。
I tried to run this down. It seems like it might have just been a handful of people out for a walk. People in the group were noting all sorts of situations where suddenly they, white people, were in the minority. And they didn't like it. White kids were outnumbered by Somali kids in music class, four or five to one. Someone in the group actually counted them up.
我试图查明这一点。看起来可能只是少数人出来散步。该组织的人注意到各种各样的情况，突然他们，白人，成了少数群体。他们不喜欢它。音乐课上白人孩子被索马里孩子的人数超过了，四五比一。该组织中有人实际上数了他们。
Someone in the group described going by Schmidt Park and seeing 20 to 30 Somali boys on the basketball court, mothers and kids, and quote, "no white people." This person wrote, "the entire area looked and felt taken over. It was eerie."
该组织中有人描述经过施密特公园（Schmidt Park）时看到20到30个索马里男孩在篮球场上，母亲和孩子，以及引用，“没有白人”。此人写道，“整个区域看起来和感觉上都被占领了。这令人毛骨悚然。”
They also found-- one gentleman found some Somali boys in his garage and going into neighbor's garages. And so that did not sit well. So that's when they called a neighborhood discussion, from what I understand. OK, and they said look, "you know, there's an awful lot of these people here. We need to get together and do something. We feel that our neighborhood is being taken over."
他们还发现——一位先生在车库里发现了一些索马里男孩，还进了邻居的车库。所以那不太好。所以这就是他们举行社区讨论的时候，据我所知。好的，他们说看，“你知道，这里有很多人。我们需要聚在一起做点什么。我们觉得我们的社区被占领了。”
Carol and most people I talked to insist this is not about race. I heard this over and over. "It's not about race." They say it's about money. How much are the refugees costing taxpayers? What's the drain on our county and on our school? That was the issue the group Peace in St. Cloud got organized around. Can we see an audit of how much is being spent on these Somalis?
卡罗尔和我交谈过的大多数人都坚持认为这与种族无关。我反复听到这句话。“这与种族无关。”他们说这与金钱有关。难民要花纳税人多少钱？对我们县和学校的消耗是什么？这就是“圣克劳德和平”组织起来的议题。我们能看到审计，看看这些索马里人花了多少钱吗？
I feel that they are reasonable people with legitimate concerns. And they have a right to find out what this is costing. They have a right to find out how this works, because they just do. And what I got from it is that people felt they had no say in this, that here this whole group of people from a different culture descends on the town and it's changed forever. And Governor Dayton has made the comment at least four times that, "Well, if you don't like it, you can leave." Well, no. I wouldn't leave.
我觉得他们是理智的人，有合理的关切。他们有权找出这要花多少钱。他们有权找出这是如何运作的，因为他们就是有权。我从中得到的是，人们觉得对此没有发言权，这里来自不同文化的一大群人降临到镇上，它被永远改变了。戴顿州长至少四次评论说，“好吧，如果你不喜欢它，你可以离开。”好吧，不。我不会离开。
That same month as the intimidation parade and the basketball court was the town hall, where they asked their congressman, Tom Emmer, for a ban on Muslims moving to St. Cloud, and he told them, "No, that's un-American." Soon enough, someone stepped forward saying, "No, no, no. That's perfectly American." This local opinion writer for The St. Cloud Times, a woman named AJ Kern, started going around, talking to Republican groups, gearing up to run for Congress to challenge Tom Emmer over this issue. She starts calling for a moratorium on refugees coming to Minnesota and to the US.
就在“恐吓游行”和篮球场发生的同一个月是市政厅会议，他们要求国会议员汤姆·埃默禁止穆斯林移居圣克劳德，他告诉他们，“不，这不符合美国精神。”很快，有人站出来说，“不，不，不。那是完全符合美国精神的。”这位《圣克劳德时报》的当地评论作家，一个名叫AJ·克恩（AJ Kern）的女人，开始四处走动，与共和党团体交谈，准备竞选国会议员，就这个问题挑战汤姆·埃默。她开始呼吁暂停难民进入明尼苏达州和美国。
AJ Kern spent time in Iran in the '70s, and she wrote some opinion pieces about how potentially dangerous Muslims can be. The Peace in St. Cloud group asked her to speak with them about life in Muslim countries. Kern officially announced her candidacy in February of 2016. In her speeches, she talked about the terrorist attacks happening in France and Belgium, the one in San Bernardino, the Syrian migrant crisis. She warned there is no way for the US or foreign governments to vet which refugee might be a terrorist.
AJ·克恩70年代在伊朗待过，她写了一些关于穆斯林可能有多危险的评论文章。“圣克劳德和平”组织请她和他们谈谈穆斯林国家的生活。克恩于2016年2月正式宣布参选。在她的演讲中，她谈到了发生在法国和比利时的恐怖袭击，圣贝纳迪诺的那起，叙利亚移民危机。她警告说，美国或外国政府无法审核哪位难民可能是恐怖分子。
If there's no government office in Syria, with a computer in some corner office that has a database to say who each Muhammad is-- was there one in Somalia? It's the same war-torn terrorist hotbed country.
如果叙利亚没有政府办公室，在某个角落办公室里有一台计算机，有一个数据库来说明每个穆罕默德是谁——索马里有一个吗？同样是饱受战争蹂躏的恐怖分子温床国家。
That's from her announcement speech at the Pickled Loon, a bar in downtown St. Cloud. Bobby, my Minnesota Republican worrier from the convention, he went to some of her events, and they disturbed him.
那是她在大楼中心的一家酒吧“Pickled Loon”的宣布演讲。鲍比，我来自代表大会的明尼苏达共和党忧虑者，他参加了她的一些活动，它们让他感到不安。
She told this imaginary story to everyone. And it was just-- it was an older crowd. And so it was "imagine your granddaughter comes home now one day from school, and she says, 'Grandma, I'm in love with my new boyfriend. He's right here. He's little Muhammad.'" And I immediately start like-- But then she went on, saying, "well, what happens if they fall in love and they get married? Are they going to have a Christian wedding or are they going to have a Muslim wedding?" And the people there were like, "oh my god, what kind of wedding would they have?" And then she just took it up a notch and said, "what happens when little Muhammad and your granddaughter have children of their own? And they're Muslim now, and so Muslims-- genital mutilation is part of their culture. And so what are you going to do when little Muhammad wants to do that to your great-grandchildren?"
她向大家讲了这个虚构的故事。它只是——这是一个年长的群体。所以它是“想象你的孙女现在有一天放学回家，她说，‘奶奶，我爱上了我的新男朋友。他就在这儿。他是小穆罕默德。’”我立即开始像——但随后她继续说，“好吧，如果他们坠入爱河并结婚了会发生什么？他们会举行基督教婚礼还是穆斯林婚礼？”在场的人就像，“天哪，他们会举行什么样的婚礼？”然后她把事情提升了一个档次说，“当小穆罕默德和你的孙女有了自己的孩子会发生什么？他们现在是穆斯林了，所以穆斯林——生殖器切割是他们文化的一部分。所以当小穆罕默德想对你的曾孙做这件事时，你会怎么做？”
And not all of the group, but when some of the groups were like, oh my gosh, I don't know what I'll do. Thank you for bringing this to my attention. That's when I was like, wow, this is an issue. This line of thinking is an issue.
并非所有群体，但当一些群体就像，噢天哪，我不知道我会做什么。谢谢你让我注意到这一点。那时我就像，哇，这是一个议题。这种思维方式是一个议题。
Kern ended up losing the sixth district congressional race to Tom Emmer. It wasn't even close. But in Stearns County, where most of St. Cloud is, she won by 77 votes. That's about as big a divide as you can get between two Republican candidates. About 3,500 people voted. Carol Rupar, head of the Republican Party in St. Cloud, the one who met with me in Caribou Coffee and told me about the mosque, she did not vote for AJ Kern in the primary. But she thinks she understands what Kern's supporters were drawn to. They're anxious about things changing too fast.
克恩最终在第六区国会竞选中输给了汤姆·埃默。甚至不接近。但在斯特恩斯县（Stearns County），圣克劳德大部分所在地，她赢了77票。那是两个共和党候选人之间可能出现的最大分歧。大约3500人投票。圣克劳德共和党负责人卡罗尔·鲁帕，那个在卡里布咖啡馆和我见面并告诉我清真寺情况的人，她在初选中没有投给AJ·克恩。但她认为她明白克恩的支持者被什么所吸引。他们对事情变化太快感到焦虑。
Carol feels the same way. She's lived in this area all her life. She grew up on a farm. Today, she's a realtor. And she does this thing. When she wants to say something even slightly controversial, she does this grimace. Like, "hmm, I don't know, but maybe." That's the face she gives me when she tells me this story to explain what motivates the Peace in St. Cloud group.
卡罗尔也有同样的感觉。她一生都住在这个地区。她在农场长大。今天，她是一名房地产经纪人。她做这件事。当她想说一些稍微有争议的话时，她会做这个鬼脸。比如，“嗯，我不知道，但也许。”这就是她告诉我这个故事以解释是什么激励了“圣克劳德和平”组织时给我的表情。
Well, and I had a little granddaughter-- have a little granddaughter. When she was three, she was at Crossroads. And there's that little play area.
嗯，我有一个小孙女——有一个小孙女。她三岁时，她在十字路口（Crossroads）。那里有那个小游乐区。
Crossroads is a mall in St. Cloud.
十字路口是圣克劳德的一个购物中心。
And her mother and a friend were chatting, and they let the kids play in this area. And so my little granddaughter-- and she's a blue-eyed blonde. And she was about three. And so this little boy was talking to her, and nice. So no problem. He was a little Somali boy. All of a sudden, he grabbed her around the neck and shoved her head into the wall. And she had a lump on the side of her head, like you took a baseball or a softball and cut it in half. She had this lump on the side of her head. She had to go to the emergency room. But that's behavior that we haven't seen.
她的母亲和一个朋友在聊天，她们让孩子们在那个区域玩。所以我的小孙女——她是金发碧眼。她大概三岁。所以这个小男孩在和她说话，很好。所以没问题。他是一个小索马里男孩。突然，他抓住她的脖子，把她的头撞向墙壁。她头侧面有一个肿块，就像你拿一个棒球或垒球切成两半。她头侧面有这个肿块。她必须去急诊室。但那是我们没见过的行为。
That felt new to you, even though those are three-year-olds, right?
即使那是三岁的孩子，那对你来说感觉也是新的，对吧？
Right, I know. But she was told that-- well, this little boy was probably four or five, but that is not normal behavior that a child would do, that it's learned behavior. I don't know if it is or not. So now, after that, that was the end. They were never allowed to go back. She never let them play in that play area again.
对，我知道。但有人告诉她——好吧，这个小男孩大概四五岁，但这不是孩子会做的正常行为，这是习得的行为。我不知道是不是。所以现在，在那之后，那是终点。她们再也不被允许回去了。她再也没让她们在那个游乐区玩过。
You're worried. You're worried that things are changing.
你很担心。你担心事情正在改变。
Yeah, so I think that's it. When people see things that are not what they're used to, that's scary. I think the Peace in St. Cloud group is trying very hard. They want peace in here, in St. Cloud, but don't run over us. We're here, and we like it the way it is. So don't change it.
是的，所以我认为是这样。当人们看到他们不习惯的事情时，那是可怕的。我认为“圣克劳德和平”组织正在非常努力。他们想要和平，在这里，在圣克劳德，但不要压倒我们。我们在这儿，我们喜欢现在的样子。所以不要改变它。
Of course, there were other ways for her to think about this incident at the mall. Like, this kid is emotionally disturbed. He had a bad day. There's something upsetting at home. Kids just hit each other sometimes. She could have concluded any of those things rather than "we're being run over by Muslim immigrants who behave differently than we do." One reason that's where she went was that this was the explanation that was emerging all around her. People were talking about Muslim immigrants at meetings, on her e-mail, on Facebook, and at talks that were popping up in the area.
当然，她还有其他方式来考虑商场里的这起事件。比如，这个孩子情绪不安。他度过了糟糕的一天。家里有些令人不安的事情。孩子们有时只是互相打架。她本可以得出任何这些结论，而不是“我们正在被行为与我们不同的穆斯林移民所践踏。”她会那样想的一个原因是，这是她周围正在出现的解释。人们在会议上、在她的电子邮件中、在Facebook上以及在该地区涌现的讲座中谈论穆斯林移民。
This was another new development in St. Cloud. Central Minnesota was becoming a place where speakers were coming, speakers who spread the word about their perceived threat of Muslim immigration. Three years ago, 2013, Carol had gone to one of these talks in Little Falls, just outside St. Cloud. It was sponsored by the Central Minnesota Tea Party. She even bought the book written by the speaker, Brigitte Gabriel. It's called Because They Hate. She has not read all of it.
这是圣克劳德的另一个新发展。明尼苏达州中部正在成为演讲者到来的地方，演讲者传播关于他们感知的穆斯林移民威胁的消息。三年前，2013年，卡罗尔去过圣克劳德外小瀑布（Little Falls）参加过其中一次讲座。它由明尼苏达州中部茶党（Tea Party）赞助。她甚至买了演讲者布丽吉特·加布里埃尔（Brigitte Gabriel）写的书。书名叫《因为他们仇恨》（Because They Hate）。她没有全部读完。
Zoe Chace. Coming up, Zoe goes to one of those meetings, where they talk about Muslim immigrants, and she meets an elected official who believes that Sharia law has already taken over American cities. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
佐伊·蔡斯。接下来，佐伊将参加那些会议中的一个，他们在会上谈论穆斯林移民，她遇到了一个相信沙里亚法（Sharia law）已经接管美国城市的民选官员。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Will I Know Anyone at This Party?
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《在这个派对上我会认识谁？》。
So if you're just tuning in, we've been talking about how the Republican party is changing this year. Lots of Republican voters apparently are not so excited about the old Republican stuff, like shrinking the size of government and having free trade. Instead, this year, they are excited about cracking down on immigration. Zoe Chace is doing a story about St. Cloud, Minnesota, which is one of the front lines of this conflict in the party.
所以如果你刚收听，我们一直在谈论共和党今年是如何改变的。许多共和党选民显然对旧的共和党那一套并不那么兴奋，比如缩小政府规模和进行自由贸易。相反，今年，他们对打击移民感到兴奋。佐伊·蔡斯正在做一个关于明尼苏达州圣克劳德的故事，这是该党冲突的前线之一。
In her reporting, Zoe went to a talk-- they have lots of talks like this out there-- about the dangers of Muslim immigration to the United States. We pick up her story from there.
在她的报道中，佐伊参加了一场讲座——他们在那里有很多这样的讲座——关于穆斯林移民对美国的危险。我们从那里继续她的故事。
One of the repeat speakers on the circuit is a local guy named Ron Branstner.
巡回演讲的重复演讲者之一是当地一个名叫罗恩·布兰斯特纳（Ron Branstner）的家伙。
First off, what we want to do is we want to stand up. We always say the Pledge of Allegiance.
首先，我们要做的是我们想要站起来。我们总是说效忠誓言。
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America.
我效忠美利坚合众国的国旗。
Ron Branstner, he's kind of bumbling and informal, but he does not hesitate to get up in front of a crowd and claim his authority on how immigration works.
罗恩·布兰斯特纳，他有点笨拙和非正式，但他毫不犹豫地站在人群面前，声称他在移民如何运作方面的权威。
There  is a movement that is going throughout the United States to try to change our culture, try to change who  we are.
有一个运动正在整个美国进行，试图改变我们的文化，试图改变我们是谁。
He spent time in California, where he volunteered as a Minuteman along the US-Mexico border to help spot people crossing illegally. He lives in the St. Cloud area. He has a super regular job in which he deals with the public, so doesn't want me to say what that is. He's become a sort of traveling prophet. He warns about the bad things that will happen to your town when the new group of immigrants come. He used to do these presentations about Mexicans, but as immigration from Latin America slowed and refugee resettlement increased in Minnesota, it seems he picked up a Quran and swapped out Mexicans for Muslims.
他在加利福尼亚州待过，在那里他作为民兵在美墨边境做志愿者，帮助发现非法越境的人。他住在圣克劳德地区。他有一份非常常规的工作，在工作中他与公众打交道，所以不想让我说那是什么。他已成为某种旅行先知。他警告当新移民群体来到你的城镇时，你的城镇会发生坏事。他过去常做这些关于墨西哥人的演示，但随着来自拉丁美洲的移民减慢，明尼苏达州的难民安置增加，他似乎拿起了一本《古兰经》，用穆斯林取代了墨西哥人。
I saw him in person at a meeting in Aberdeen, South Dakota, which isn't far from the Minnesota border.
我亲自在南达科他州阿伯丁（Aberdeen）的一次会议上看到了他，那里离明尼苏达州边界不远。
So what you see now and what you see five years from now, you're not going to recognize the state.
所以你现在看到的和你五年后看到的，你将认不出这个州。
Ron Branstner is where a lot of the members of the Peace in St. Cloud group get their ideas. He has a lot of theories, a lot of slides. I'm going to sum up those theories in three parts.
罗恩·布兰斯特纳是“圣克劳德和平”组织的许多成员获得他们想法的地方。他有很多理论，很多幻灯片。我将把这些理论总结为三部分。
One, refugees are costing you money. Branstner is very specific about this. It's costing taxpayers $14,000 per immigrant.
一，难民正在消耗你的钱。布兰斯特纳对此非常具体。每个移民花费纳税人14,000美元。
You are not contributing to the United States at all. You are a welfare case.
你根本没有为美国做出贡献。你是一个福利案例。
Two, nonprofits are getting rich off bringing refugees into Minnesota. This is something I heard from a lot of people. I also heard repeatedly that there is no transparency, no audit, no one has any idea how they're tax money is spent by non-profits on refugees.
二，非营利组织通过带难民进入明尼苏达州发了财。这是我从很多人那里听到的事情。我也反复听到没有透明度，没有审计，没有人知道他们的税款被非营利组织花在难民身上是多少。
And it's a moneymaker beyond anything. It's the largest industry, probably, in the world, moneywise.
而且这是一个超越一切的赚钱机器。它是世界上最大的产业，可能，在金钱方面。
Three, and this is the one that really riles people up, as soon as enough Muslim refugees get to your town, they will institute Sharia law as the law of the land.
三，这是真正让人们愤怒的一点，只要有足够的穆斯林难民来到你的城镇，他们就会将沙里亚法确立为该地的法律。
Sharia is Islamic religious law as derived from the Quran and other religious texts and scholarship. It's not an all spelled out thing, like the Ten Commandments. Branstner says women will become second-class citizens, non-believers will be killed. Basically, Central Minnesota becomes part of the caliphate.
沙里亚是伊斯兰宗教法，源于《古兰经》和其他宗教文本和学术。它不是一个完全拼写出来的东西，像《十诫》。布兰斯特纳说妇女将成为二等公民，不信教的人将被杀害。基本上，明尼苏达州中部变成了哈里发国（caliphate）的一部分。
Because they did a study and a large percentage of the new immigrants in this country want Sharia law. I studied the Quran every day for two hours. I know the Quran. I know Islam. Sharia law does not believe in man-made laws. It's against the religion. All laws come from their god. If you go outside of their laws in Sharia, you will be considered apostate and you will die.
因为他们做了一项研究，在这个国家的新移民中有很大一部分人想要沙里亚法。我每天研究《古兰经》两个小时。我了解《古兰经》。我了解伊斯兰教。沙里亚法不相信人造法律。它违反宗教。所有法律都来自他们的神。如果你在沙里亚法之外行事，你将被视为叛教者，你就会死。
Ron concludes his talk by explaining Hillary Clinton has taken an oath that she will punish anyone who speaks ill of Islam when she is president.
罗恩结束了他的演讲，解释说希拉里·克林顿（Hillary Clinton）发誓，当她是总统时，她将惩罚任何诋毁伊斯兰教的人。
I want to thank Aberdeen for everything!
我要感谢阿伯丁所做的一切！
OK, this presentation seems to be pretty effective with the people in this room in Aberdeen. They really want information. This feels like information. 200-odd people in there, most of them applaud and put money in the basket. There are a few people who aren't buying it. One woman runs out in tears yelling, "you're crazy."
好的，这个演讲对在阿伯丁那个房间里的人似乎相当有效。他们真的想要信息。这感觉像是信息。200多人在那里，他们大多数鼓掌并将钱放入篮子。有些人不买账。一个女人哭着跑出去大喊，“你疯了。”
You are really crazy!
你真的疯了！
[CHEERING]
（欢呼）
At one point, an American Indian stands up to address the crowd saying, "You are all illegal immigrants."
有一次，一个美国印第安人站起来向人群讲话，说，“你们都是非法移民。”
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The entire room burst out laughing. Somehow, this joke works for everyone. Although, of course, it's not a joke.
整个房间爆发出笑声。不知何故，这个笑话对每个人都有效。虽然，当然，它不是一个笑话。
I want to say clearly here the overall message of Ron Branstner's presentation is not true. He's right that the refugee resettlement program is a federal program. Locals don't have a say in it. But St. Cloud taxpayers are not getting screwed by this program. Ron's claim that each immigrant costs taxpayers $14,000 comes from this widely discredited study on the cost of the amnesty, which, anyway, is a separate issue.
我想在这里明确指出，罗恩·布兰斯特纳演讲的总体信息是不真实的。他是对的，难民安置计划是一个联邦计划。当地人对它没有发言权。但圣克劳德的纳税人并没有被这个计划搞砸。罗恩声称每个移民花费纳税人14,000美元来自于这项被广泛抹黑的研究，关于特赦的成本，无论如何，这是一个单独的议题。
The economic consensus is that in the long run, immigrants do not cost taxpayers money. Yes, they use government services. That's generally offset by the taxes they pay and the fact that their presence expands the economy. It is true that refugee resettlement programs often put a strain on hospitals and schools initially, because they aren't necessarily prepared for the influx. Interpreters, for example, do cost St. Cloud's county an increasing amount of money, about $250,000 in the last year. But this is out of an annual budget of $54 million. As for the nonprofits who settle refugees in Minnesota, they get $2,025 per refugee from the State Department. Most of that, they spend on the refugees.
经济共识是，从长远来看，移民不会消耗纳税人的钱。是的，他们使用政府服务。这通常被他们支付的税款和他们的存在扩大了经济的事实所抵消。确实，难民安置计划通常最初会给医院和学校带来压力，因为他们不一定为涌入做好了准备。例如，口译员确实花费了圣克劳德县越来越多的钱，去年大约是25万美元。但这是在5400万美元的年度预算中。至于在明尼苏达州安置难民的非营利组织，他们从国务院获得每位难民2025美元。他们把大部分钱花在了难民身上。
In this hotel ballroom in Aberdeen, South Dakota, people aren't interested in a debate over the economics of immigration. This is a conversation about fear. The most memorable conversation I had was with this state rep Al Novstrup. He's been in state government for 14 years, and he came to this meeting to get more information on Sharia law potentially taking over his city. Like it has other places, he says.
在这个南达科他州阿伯丁的酒店宴会厅里，人们对移民经济学的辩论不感兴趣。这是一场关于恐惧的对话。我印象最深的一次对话是与这位州代表阿尔·诺夫斯特鲁普（Al Novstrup）的谈话。他在州政府工作了14年，他来参加这次会议是为了获得更多关于沙里亚法可能接管他城市的潜在信息。他说，就像在其他地方一样。
Like where?
像哪里？
Dearborn, Michigan?
密歇根州迪尔伯恩（Dearborn）？
Have you seen that happen there?
你在那里看到过这种情况吗？
I haven't been to Dearborn, Michigan.
我没去过密歇根州迪尔伯恩。
From my perspective, as a national reporter, there's still the Constitution. There's no Sharia anywhere.
从我的角度来看，作为一名全国记者，仍然有宪法。没有任何地方有沙里亚。
You don't think there's Sharia anywheres in the United States?
你不认为美国任何地方有沙里亚吗？
Correct.
正确。
I think you need to read more.
我认为你需要多读书。
I do read.
我是读书的。
You don't think there's Sharia any place in the United States? You don't think-- wow. OK. You don't think there's Sharia? I'm just blown away. We're living on two different planets.
你不认为美国任何地方有沙里亚吗？你不认为——哇。好的。你不认为有沙里亚？我只是被震惊了。我们生活在两个不同的星球上。
Sharia is a really big talking point in pushing for a moratorium on refugees. The mayor of St. Cloud, Dave Kleis, told me he heard that rumor about Dearborn so many times he finally picked up the phone and called a member of Dearborn city council-- the city is about 40% Arab American-- and double-checked. Sharia law does not govern Dearborn or anywhere else in the United States.
沙里亚是一个在推动暂停难民方面很大的谈话要点。圣克劳德市长戴夫·克莱斯（Dave Kleis）告诉我，他听到关于迪尔伯恩的那个传言太多次了，他最终拿起电话给迪尔伯恩市议会的一名成员打了电话——该城市约40%是阿拉伯裔美国人——并进行了复核。沙里亚法并不管理迪尔伯恩或美国的任何其他地方。
Another talking point, the weirdest one, Somalis are systematically ruining rental properties by either trying to plant crops inside their apartments or raise fish in their bathtubs. I heard this in Minnesota and South Dakota both, the same basic story. This is how this movement works. It looks homegrown and grassroots in a hotel ballroom with xeroxed handouts, but all the things Branstner talks about-- Sharia, multiple wives multiplying the demographic changes, the Muslim Brotherhood plan to take over the government-- there is a national movement of people repeating these things all over the country and they're all saying the same thing. They feed off each other.
另一个谈话要点，最奇怪的一个，索马里人正在系统地破坏租赁房产，要么试图在公寓里种植农作物，要么在浴缸里养鱼。我在明尼苏达州和南达科他州都听到了这个，基本相同的故事。这就是这场运动运作的方式。它在酒店宴会厅里看起来像是本土的和基层的，有复印的讲义，但布兰斯特纳谈论的所有事情——沙里亚，多个妻子增加人口统计学变化，穆斯林兄弟会接管政府的计划——全国各地有一场重复这些事情的运动，他们都在说同样的事情。他们互相喂养。
Nationally, a major group pushing the same anti-Muslim talking points, it's called ACT for America. It has local chapters in many states, kind of built off the Tea Party. Peace in St. Cloud recently morphed into an ACT for America chapter. One of the members just told me. ACT for America coordinates much of its work with this thinktank in DC, called the Center for Security Policy. The Southern Poverty Law Center now classifies both as hate groups.
在全国范围内，一个推动同样反穆斯林谈话要点的主要组织，它叫“ACT for America”。它在许多州有当地分支机构，有点建立在茶党的基础上。“圣克劳德和平”最近演变成了“ACT for America”的一个分支。其中一名成员刚才告诉我的。ACT for America与华盛顿特区的一家智库协调其大部分工作，名为“安全政策中心”（Center for Security Policy）。南方贫困法律中心（Southern Poverty Law Center）现在将两者都归类为仇恨团体。
What this means is that if you're someone who lives in St. Cloud, or Wilmar, or Aberdeen, and you're worried about a mosque coming to your neighborhood, or a random parade going by weirds you out, and you google, say, "mosque, refugees, zoning," there is a whole web of anti-Muslim information sources out there, ready to respond to you. Like the blog Refugee Resettlement Watch, Creeping Sharia, all informed by the work of ACT for America and the Center for Security Policy. And then there you are-- you have a connection to speakers, and tactics, and talking points. It's this interconnected web of misinformation.
这意味着，如果你是一个住在圣克劳德、威尔马或阿伯丁的人，担心清真寺来到你的社区，或者偶然经过的游行让你感到奇怪，你谷歌，比如，“清真寺，难民，分区”，外面有一个完整的反穆斯林信息来源网络，准备好回应你。比如博客“难民安置观察”、“爬行的沙里亚”，所有这些都受到“ACT for America”和“安全政策中心”工作的启发。然后你就有了——你与演讲者、策略和谈话要点有了联系。这是一个相互关联的虚假信息网络。
Then there's this national speaker.
然后还有这位全国演讲者。
And then I looked at poll numbers. And I don't mean polls where I'm winning. Those numbers I like looking at. These numbers I hated to look at.
然后我看了民调数字。我不是指我获胜的民调。那些数字我喜欢看。这些数字我讨厌看。
Here's Donald Trump announcing his Muslim ban idea back in December in South Carolina.
这是唐纳德·特朗普去年12月在南卡罗来纳州宣布他的穆斯林禁令想法。
25% of those polls-- and this was from the Center for Security Policy, a very highly respected group of people who I know, actually--
这些民调的25%——这是来自安全政策中心，一个非常受人尊敬的人群，我认识的，实际上——
The Center for Security Policy, the group that works with ACT for America.
安全政策中心，那个与ACT for America合作的组织。
25% of those polls agreed violence against Americans is justified as Muslims. 25%. 51%-- 51%, highly respected number of polling groups, want to be governed according to Sharia. You know what Sharia is.
这些民调的25%同意对美国人的暴力是穆斯林正当的。25%。51%——51%，高度受尊敬的民调团体数字，想要被沙里亚统治。你知道沙里亚是什么。
These poll numbers have been discredited. And groups like the Center for Security Policy weren't just giving talking points to Donald Trump. They had people on Ted Cruz's campaign. And they fed the same ideas to speakers in little towns and cities like St. Cloud. This created a receptive audience for any political candidate making those talking points.
这些民调数字已被抹黑。像安全政策中心这样的组织不仅给唐纳德·特朗普提供了谈话要点。他们有泰德·克鲁兹（Ted Cruz）竞选团队的人。他们将同样的想法喂给了像圣克劳德这样的小城镇和城市的演讲者。这为任何提出这些谈话要点的政治候选人创造了一个易受影响的受众。
The Somalis in town or not just passively watching the white people fight among themselves about Muslim refugees, of course. There are also small organized groups trying to push a different message in St. Cloud about new immigrants. They have speakers too. You can get really busy in St. Cloud, actually, going to speakers and panels on both sides of this thing.
城里的索马里人当然不仅是被动地看着白人在他们之间为穆斯林难民而战。在圣克劳德也有试图在关于新移民方面推动不同信息的小型组织。他们也有演讲者。实际上，你可以在圣克劳德非常忙碌，去参加双方关于这件事的演讲和小组讨论。
My name is Ayan Omar, and I am a Somali refugee Muslim American.
我的名字叫阿扬·奥马尔（Ayan Omar），我是一名索马里难民穆斯林美国人。
I met Ayan Omar at this interfaith dialogue meeting at St. Joseph's Church in St. Joseph, Minnesota, 15 minutes away from St. Cloud. She does these panels where she goes around to churches and tells her story of being a Somali Muslim refugee in America. Ayan's intense. She's 28, bright white hijab, dark red lipstick. When she does these panels, she takes questions. And the people in the room write them down on a piece of paper so that they're anonymous and pass them to the front. The questions are remarkably candid. Father Peter Meyer reads them out.
我在明尼苏达州圣约瑟夫（St. Joseph）的圣约瑟夫教堂的这次信仰间对话会议上遇到了阿扬·奥马尔，离圣克劳德15分钟路程。她做这些小组讨论，她去各个教堂讲述她在美作为索马里穆斯林难民的故事。阿扬很强烈。她28岁，明亮的白头巾，深红色口红。当她做这些小组时，她接受提问。房间里的人把它们写在纸上，这样它们是匿名的，并传到前面。问题非常坦率。彼得·迈耶（Peter Meyer）神父把它们读出来。
I've been told by several reliable sources that Muslims believe that people that are not Muslim are to be destroyed. This makes me fearful. Please help me understand.
我被几个可靠的消息来源告知，穆斯林相信不是穆斯林的人应该被摧毁。这让我感到恐惧。请帮我理解。
OK, so I was raised in the way that the Quran says-- "if you take one life, it's as if you've taken all of humanity."
好的，所以我是按照《古兰经》说的成长起来的——“如果你夺走一个生命，就好像你夺走了全人类。”
Ayan goes on and explains the Five Pillars of Islam and does this demonstration for the room, how she prays five times a day.
阿扬继续解释伊斯兰教的五功，并为房间做了这个演示，她如何每天祈祷五次。
At sundown and right before [INAUDIBLE]
在日落时和[听不清]之前
She kneels and touches her head to the church floor. People stand on their tiptoes to see. The next question, "Are Muslims allowed to be polygamous? Do we have to pay for multiple wives?" Jama, people call him an elder in the Somali community, he takes this question.
她跪下，头触及教堂地板。人们踮起脚尖看。下一个问题，“穆斯林可以多妻吗？我们必须为多个妻子买单吗？”贾马（Jama），人们称他为索马里社区的长老，他接受了这个提问。
I say, OK. Here, in the United States, we are allowed to have one wife. So we abide by the rule, and we have one wife. But--
我说，好的。在这里，在美国，我们被允许有一个妻子。所以我们遵守规则，我们有一个妻子。但是——
The room tenses up.
房间变得紧张起来。
As I learned here in the States, you can have one wife, but you can have five or six girlfriends.
正如我在美国所学到的，你可以有一个妻子，但你可以有五个或六个女朋友。
Ayan is a teacher at a high school in town and she's the mother of a three-year-old. When she hears that people feel afraid of Muslims, she says, "I understand having a feeling. You can't argue with a feeling."
阿扬是镇上一所高中的老师，她是一个三岁孩子的母亲。当她听到人们害怕穆斯林时，她说，“我理解有一种感觉。你不能反驳一种感觉。”
To those individuals who are afraid, or who feel threatened, or who feel that their world is shaking, you have a right to feel that way. You don't have a right to lash out. I tell my daughter this whenever she cries. I say, "It's OK to cry." And when she gets angry, "It's OK to be angry. Everyone gets angry. But you don't have a right to slam the doors."
对于那些害怕的，或觉得被威胁的，或觉得他们的世界正在动摇的人，你有权利那样感觉。你没有权利猛烈抨击。我告诉我的女儿，每当她哭时。我说，“哭是可以的。”当她生气时，“生气是可以的。每个人都会生气。但你没有权利关上门。”
The way she sees it is like St. Cloud is having a tantrum. And tantrums end. So she's patient. She's an optimist about St. Cloud. There are plenty of people in the city that don't feel this way at all. And for those who do, they just learned bad information. She can win them back by giving them good information.
在她看来，就像圣克劳德正在发脾气。脾气会结束的。所以她很有耐心。她是一个关于圣克劳德的乐观主义者。城里有很多人根本没有这种感觉。而对于那些有的人，他们只是了解了错误的信息。她可以通过给他们正确的信息赢回他们。
Then, in September--
然后，在9月——
Breaking news out of St. Cloud tonight. The Crossroads Mall remains on lockdown after several people were stabbed.
今晚来自圣克劳德的突发新闻。十字路口商场在几个人被刺伤后仍然处于封锁状态。
On September 17, there was a stabbing at Crossroads Mall in St. Cloud, Minnesota, same place actually that Carol's granddaughter got hit in the head. It was national news. You probably heard about it. Both presidential candidates have addressed it. It was a violent and awful act, this guy running around the mall with two knives, asking people if they're Muslim. Nine people ended up at the hospital. All were released by the next day. The guy who did it was Somali Muslim refugee American. He was killed by an off-duty police officer. Again, here's Ayan.
9月17日，明尼苏达州圣克劳德的十字路口商场发生了刺伤事件，实际上就是卡罗尔孙女被撞到头的地方。这是全国新闻。你可能听说过。两位总统候选人都谈到了它。这是一个暴力且糟糕的行为，这家伙拿着两把刀在商场里跑来跑去，问人们是否是穆斯林。九个人最终进了医院。所有人第二天都出院了。做这件事的人是索马里穆斯林难民美国人。他被一名下班警察打死了。再次，这里是阿扬。
You know, it's funny. I was at the mall. I missed it by 15 minutes. I was shopping at Kohl's and I received a text message, just as I was checking out. "Hey, are you still at the mall?" I said, "No, I left. Sorry. If you wanted to go, maybe we can go some other time." She goes, "No, didn't you hear?" I said, "hear what?" She said, "Oh, there was a stabbing."
你知道，这很有趣。我在商场。我错过了它15分钟。我在Kohl's购物，我收到一条短信，就在我结账时。“嘿，你还在商场吗？”我说，“不，我离开了。抱歉。如果你想去，也许我们可以改天去。”她说，“不，你没听说吗？”我说，“听说什么？”她说，“哦，发生了一起刺伤事件。”
And I went online and I read it. And I remember thinking, oh, please, don't let it be a Muslim. Don't let it be Somali. Because I've been working so hard and creating a community. This, I don't need this. And then I found out. It was a heavy-hearted week, emotionally exhausting.
我上网读了它。我记得我心想，哦，拜托，不要是穆斯林。不要是索马里人。因为我一直努力工作并建立一个社区。这个，我不需要这个。然后我发现了。那是沉重的一周，情绪上筋疲力尽。
In St. Cloud, there were two ways to read the stabbing. For the people who wanted a moratorium, it was proof. Some people I'd been talking to for months were like, "I told you so. We knew it would come to this." To be clear, they were scared of violent extremism. One guy told me the day after the stabbing he applied for a carry license. For those on the other side, unity rallies, press conferences, Somali leaders in the area running around, giving interview after our interview, saying that guy does not represent all Muslims.
在圣克劳德，有两种方式解读刺伤事件。对于想要暂停的人，这是证据。我和我聊了几个月的一些人就像，“我告诉过你。我们知道会发生这种情况。”需要明确的是，他们害怕暴力极端主义。一个人告诉我，刺伤事件后的一天，他申请了持枪许可。对于另一边的人，团结集会、新闻发布会、该地区的索马里领袖跑来跑去，接受了一次又一次采访，说那个家伙不代表所有穆斯林。
AM 1450, FM 1033, KNSI's Ox in the Afternoon.
AM 1450，FM 1033，KNSI的午后公牛。
Congressman Emmer went on talk radio right after the stabbing, trying to keep everyone calm on all sides.
埃默议员在刺伤事件后立刻上了脱口秀电台，试图让双方的人冷静下来。
If somebody commits an act, like we saw on Saturday night, it really drives a deep concern in the community-- fear.
如果有人犯下行为，就像我们在周六晚上看到的那样，它确实在社区中驱动了一种深深的担忧——恐惧。
He knows that his constituents who want a moratorium on Muslims now, they want it more than ever. The old Peace in St. Cloud/ACT for America group met up the week of the stabbing. So did AJ Kern's supporters. One of them tells me they're gearing up either for her next campaign or someone with the same message to replace Tom Emmer.
他知道他的选民中那些现在想要禁止穆斯林的人，他们比以往任何时候都想要它。旧的“圣克劳德和平”/ACT for America组织在刺伤事件那一周碰面了。AJ·克恩的支持者也一样。其中一个告诉我，他们正在准备她的下一次竞选或某人带着同样的信息来取代汤姆·埃默。
When I spoke with Emmer, he told me something like what Ayan might say. These are good people in his party who came under the influence of bad information. And you have to let them vent, and you have to listen, and then figure out what to do.
当我与埃默交谈时，他告诉了我一些像阿扬可能会说的话。这些是他党内的好人，他们受到了错误信息的影响。你必须让他们发泄，你必须倾听，然后找出要做什么。
I can give you this. I think it went on far too long. I think nobody confronting this allowed it to grow past what people in St. Cloud are comfortable with and people within the Republican small group are comfortable with.
我可以给你这个。我认为它持续的时间太长了。我认为没有人面对这一点让它发展到了超越圣克劳德人们感到舒服以及共和党小群体内人们感到舒服的地步。
The local Republican Party, just like the national one, has to figure out where it's going to stand on this issue going forward. Are they going to be a party that welcomes immigrants, refugees, Muslims, or not? The problem for Emmer is, his constituents went from having no opinion on the Somalis to a really strong opinion. Once that switch has been flipped, once voters have decided they want Somalis out, it might be hard to flip it back.
当地共和党，就像全国的一样，必须弄清楚在这个议题上它未来将站在哪里。他们将成为一个欢迎移民、难民、穆斯林的政党，还是不？对于埃默的问题是，他的选民从对索马里人没有意见变成了非常强烈的意见。一旦那个开关被翻转，一旦选民决定他们想要索马里人离开，可能很难把它翻回来。
I met up with Bobby again before I left St. Cloud, in the Coon Rapids IHOP. He's been in lots of those conversations already, including this one that summarizes the problem facing the party pretty succinctly.
我在离开圣克劳德前再次遇到了鲍比，在库恩拉皮兹的IHOP。他已经参加了许多那些对话，包括总结政党面临的问题的这一场，非常简洁。
I remember one time a guy stood up at one of the other meetings. And he's active in the party. He's one of the better volunteers in the area. Everyone loves him, but he just stood up and he said, "This is why we lose. Whether you're right or wrong, you're coming off extremely racist. And if you want to make an argument that the reason the refugees coming is bad is because economically this, that, the other, we'll have that conversation, but right now it sounds like refugees are bad because they're Muslims." And he was pretty passionate about it. He got up and left. And he said the right thing and I think he looked better for it. But everyone else was like, oh, wow. I can't believe he thought we were racist. We said we're not racist.
我记得有一次一个人在其他会议中的一个上站了起来。他积极参与党内活动。他是该地区最好的志愿者之一。每个人都爱他，但他只是站起来说，“这就是我们输的原因。无论你是对是错，你看起来都极其种族主义。如果你想做一个论点，难民来是因为坏是因为经济上的这个、那个，其他的，我们会进行那个对话，但现在听起来难民是坏的，因为他们是穆斯林。”他对此相当热情。他站起来离开了。他说了正确的话，我认为他看起来更好。但其他每个人就像，噢，哇。我不相信他认为我们是种族主义者。我们说我们不是种族主义者。
That guy got up and left. Bobby is still in it. He still goes to his local party meetings in a slightly different part of the state. I asked Bobby, is the Republican Party going to be more like you in the future or more Donald Trump? And he said, "I see that conflict as between old and young, and the younger people will win out." And in the long run, sure. The short run, though, it's going to be messy.
那个家伙站起来离开了。鲍比仍然在其中。他仍然去他州稍微不同部分的当地党派会议。我问鲍比，共和党在未来会更像你还是更像唐纳德·特朗普？他说，“我看到那种冲突是在老与少之间，而年轻人会赢。”从长远来看，当然。短期内，虽然，这将会很混乱。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our program. Act 2, Party Guy.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制片人之一。第二幕，派对家伙。
So as we said at the beginning of the show, so many people in the Republican leadership seem like tragic figures this year, not so happy with their nominee Donald Trump but having to hold their tongues. Even as his poll numbers are now looking very, very bad, they have to stick by him. The head of the Republican National Committee, Reince Priebus, he has the job of holding the whole party together, including things like trying to get his nominee to play nicely with the house leader Paul Ryan and vice versa. That is clearly a thankless, grueling job.
所以正如我们在节目开始时所说的，共和党领导层中的许多人今年看起来像悲剧人物，对他们的提名人唐纳德·特朗普并不那么高兴，但必须闭上嘴。即使他的民调数字现在看起来非常、非常糟糕，他们必须支持他。共和党全国委员会主席里恩斯·普里巴斯，他有把整个党团结在一起的工作，包括尝试让他的提名人与众议院领袖保罗·瑞安友好相处，反之亦然。那显然是一份吃力不讨好的、艰苦的工作。
We asked Broadway composer Michael Friedman, who did a political musical called Bloody, Bloody Andrew Jackson , to imagine what Reince Priebus might be thinking but not expressing publicly. John Ellison Conlee sings the part of Reince Priebus.
我们请百老汇作曲家迈克尔·弗里德曼（Michael Friedman），他做了一部政治音乐剧叫《血腥、血腥的安德鲁·杰克逊》，想象里恩斯·普里巴斯可能在想但不能公开表达的事情。约翰·埃利森·康利（John Ellison Conlee）演唱里恩斯·普里巴斯的部分。
The Speaker of the House calls and says, "Tell Trump I'm not speaking to him anymore." Then the candidate tweets [SNIFF] "Ryan's a traitor. Also, Miss Universe is a whore." A two-hour call to say, "Donald, please, just make an apology." Then Breitbart adds, "Just don't tick off the core constituency." Meanwhile, half the Republican leadership called to say, "We are shocked, shocked and appalled."
众议院议长打来电话说，“告诉特朗普我不再跟他说话了。”然后候选人发推文[吸鼻涕]“瑞安是个叛徒。而且，环球小姐是个妓女。”一个两小时的电话说，“唐纳德，拜托，道歉吧。”然后布莱巴特（Breitbart）补充说，“只是别惹火了核心选民。”与此同时，一半的共和党领导层打来电话说，“我们感到震惊，感到震惊和愤怒。”
And I just smile. I'm a party guy. Smile, toe the party line. Smile, even when you don't know why. Fox News asks me "Is Donald Trump a good role model for the youth of today?" And I say, "You know, I think everybody is a role model in their own way." My biggest donor to The New York Times, "Reince Priebus should be fired!"
而我只是微笑。我是一个派对家伙。微笑，遵循党派路线。微笑，即使你不知道为什么。福克斯新闻问我“唐纳德·特朗普是今天青少年的好榜样吗？”而我说，“你知道，我认为每个人都是以自己的方式作为榜样。”我最大的捐赠者对《纽约时报》说，“里恩斯·普里巴斯应该被解雇！”
You want to know how it's going? Honestly, I'm tired, but I smile. I'm a party guy. Smile, toe the party line. Don't let 'em see you cry. On Monday night, my finance guy told The Washington Post, "The RNC is sinking fast and it's our own fault." On Tuesday, my director of communications said he wasn't sure if grabbing genitals was sexual assault.
你想知道进展如何吗？老实说，我很累，但我微笑。我是一个派对家伙。微笑，遵循党派路线。别让他们看到你哭。周一晚上，我的财务负责人告诉《华盛顿邮报》，“共和党全国委员会正在迅速下沉，这是我们自己的错。”周二，我的通讯主管说他不确定抓生殖器是否是性侵犯。
The Wall Street Journal says, "Republicans in an all-out war," and late at night, I ask myself what were we even fighting for? Smile, you're a party guy. Smile, you can't say that I didn't try. Smile. I don't need your flipping thanks. Just don't blame me up when your country tanks.
《华尔街日报》说，“共和党处于全面战争中”，深夜，我问自己我们到底在为什么而战？微笑，你是一个派对家伙。微笑，你不能说我没尝试。微笑。我不需要你那该死的感谢。只是当你的国家完蛋时别责怪我。
You take whatever victories you can get. So I'm not pouring Bailey's in my cereal yet. Smile, whatever will be, will be. I'll still have the party, Reince and the party. The party and me.
你得到任何你能得到的胜利。所以我还没有在我的麦片里倒百利酒。微笑，无论将会发生什么，都会发生。我仍然会有派对，里恩斯和派对。派对和我。
John Ellison Conlee, arrangements and musical direction for that song by Justin Levine.
约翰·埃利森·康利，那首歌的编曲和音乐指导由贾斯汀·莱文（Justin Levine）负责。
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton and Zoe Chace. Our production staff for today's show, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Sarah Koenig, and Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Research help from Lily Sullivan, Christopher [? Sutala, ?] and Benjamin [? Failan. ?] Music help from Damian Graf.
我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和佐伊·蔡斯制作。我们今天节目的制作人员，达纳·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）、伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）、斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。来自莉莉·沙利文（Lily Sullivan）、克里斯托弗 [? Sutala, ?] 和本杰明 [? Failan. ?] 的研究帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graf）的音乐帮助。
Special thanks today Kirsty Marone, Sally Jo Sorensen, Haji Yussef, Natalie Ringsmuth, Kathleen Virnig, Linda Radin, Paul Brandmire, Sue Ek, Matt Westland, Jeffrey Baum, and Giovanni Peri, Cindy Kent, John Esposito, Engy Abdelkader, David Neiwert, Mark Sizer, Jody Avrigan, Kalia Abiade, Kevin Genachowski, Robert Costa, Mark Leibovich, and Stephen Merritt.
今天的特别感谢 Kirsty Marone, Sally Jo Sorensen, Haji Yussef, Natalie Ringsmuth, Kathleen Virnig, Linda Radin, Paul Brandmire, Sue Ek, Matt Westland, Jeffrey Baum, 和 Giovanni Peri, Cindy Kent, John Esposito, Engy Abdelkader, David Neiwert, Mark Sizer, Jody Avrigan, Kalia Abiade, Kevin Genachowski, Robert Costa, Mark Leibovich, 和 Stephen Merritt.
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who you know we hear from every week here at the end of our program. He told me he feels like he is just not getting enough airtime.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播电台交易所（PRX）分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，你知道我们每周在节目结束时都会听到他的声音。他告诉我他觉得他得到的播出时间不够。
Someone write me a big speech. I don't know the words. You give me the words, but I want a big, big, big speech.
有人帮我写个盛大的演讲稿。我不知道该用什么词。你给我提供词句，但我想要一个盛大、盛大、盛大的演讲。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《This American Life》的故事。